uh
before we started i would say uh so the
format of this
presentation is that we probably can
take questions right in the middle while
we are talking
because we are pretty familiar with the
topic and it's easy for us to answer
but we know a little bit less about you
so
it would help us to really navigate uh
of
how we describe a particular problem if
we get the questions as we go
i can say just couple words about myself
to to start this presentation
so basically my background is in drug
discovery in on biophysics or at least
it started that way
so i did my undergrad back in ukraine
and afterwards
i moved on something called fulbright
scholarship
and i stayed for a year and a half with
dr raymond kenazi
which in an antiviral discovery lab so
that club was most famous for
discovering hepatitis c cure
which is a horseblower and for a year
and a half i was working
trying to discover drugs for hepatitis b
using biophysics
and simulations and we did discover like
some interesting compounds
and uh next year i spent
uh with professor guild roberts at
harvard medical school
and then i almost finished my master's
by at mit
and then i went to do an internship with
professor israel mangia and now
i am in the process of transitioning to
my phd
and my main work here is
i'm organizing mila molecule discovery
groups and i am trying to coordinate
different projects with each other
thanks a lot maxine so hi everyone it's
uh it's a pleasure to be here and
thanks to the organizers for for hosting
us so i'm
alberta briefly i'm a phd student
at uh working with joshua benjios i'm
from france
i have a background in mathematics and
machine learning and i moved to
quebec two years ago and i started
working on
medical applications of machine learning
so i worked a bit on computer vision
and right now i focus on gene expression
data
and like a drug repurposing for this
project
and i'm like my research
plans are to try to adapt like causal
influence techniques to
gene expression data and yeah
uh it's pleasure to be here and i will
let maxim uh
present the first part of sounds good it
next slide please so i
wanted to give an overview of basically
an overarching objective of mila
molecule discovery group
so it's a pretty big group i think it
consists of right
now about 10 advisors and
there are more than 30 students involved
part-time and they think about 10 of us
full-time but we are expanding
uh and basically what is our general
direction right so what are we trying to
solve together
and it's just one single topic which is
how to better search
in the space of molecules and
under search i mean boss
discovering new molecules right so which
is basically generating molecules out on
biato modulo by block or in reaction
space whatever that would be
but it's also finding a new drug
combinations right
which is basically what are the right
dosages like how much of each drug we
want to achieve an optimal effect on
cells
and in like later boxes of human body
right and uh yeah so this these two
combine together and in the future these
two directions will actually fully
emerge
because i believe the future of drug
discovery would be to be able to
discover one drug that probably targets
more than one target at the same time
so we definitely are very much from the
very beginning interested in that
direction
uh so just to give a very broad overview
of the topics that
we are working on right uh there is
one family of topics that is really
really interesting to us and
this is how to make reinforcement
learning
to search in the space right so how to
develop reinforcement learning for
search
there are not too many published papers
so if you look at a
molecule did you know the design right
then we have
things like moldy qn or molecular ppo
from
stanford group right so and also we have
earlier presentation today from groups
like
different startups like in the ui and
then it's atomwise and others
but this are more uh of applied
reinforcement learning algorithms apply
to the search right
uh we as academia we are trying to come
up with a more fundamental way of just
writing algorithms in such a way that
from the very beginning this algorithms
are designed to do search
and what does it mean right so let's say
having a fixed compute budget right
let's say having a fixed compute budget
of let's say you have 50 gpu days for
the project for one protein
and then we want to design the best drug
usually the problem in a rail
formulation that
we want to have an algorithm right which
have something like a
value function or q function actually it
says okay given this
uh settings right given the state
predict the optimal
action to take given the value of the
next states
right but what we are really trying to
do here is we want to
go a little bit beyond that and abstract
from this usual reinforcement learning
paradigm
right and we want from the very
beginning try to write a function or a
formula
which from which would say okay so what
is the formula we have to optimize for
to achieve the best possible objective
uh which is in search given a limited
computational budget right and this
requires a lot of thinking
and this is a very long term objective
which is not so easy to solve and it
will probably take more than one paper
to come up with a solution
moreover it's probably not a single
solution to this
the next very big set of challenges or
the huge challenge that we are trying to
solve
is that it's a very very recurrent no
matter where it is
either drug combinations or is a
generative molecule discovery
there is a very non-classical for a
typical machine learning scenario
where we have different oracles and
these oracles are so different in their
cost of running
for example if i am in a reinforcement
learning setting
i can do a very cheap estimate of
molecule energy so i can come standard
size and resources learning engine comes
with some molecule proposal
that proposes some molecule graph and we
can just run message pass a neural
network and evaluate this graph
and say okay here is the energy so
whatever the distribution would be given
uncertainty
right so this is very very quick to
evaluate but if you look
what ak what's the next level of oracle
the next level of oracle would be
something like docking
so docking takes seconds and let's say
okay what's the next level of oracle
and the next level of oracle is dft and
dft is national function and theory
computation to parameterize a molecule
but also something like free energy
perturbation right and this kind of
simulation is already one day
right so looking at these three
simulations right it's already three
orders of magnitude and if you go over
right if you want to synthesize a
molecule and test it inside
say in biological assay in cell so it's
usually the speed of this kind of thing
is limited by
the production of how many molecules
they can produce
and then chemists can only produce let's
say three molecules per week right so
they usually can take three molecules in
parallel and they can produce three
molecules a week
so now there is basically three orders
of magnitude three orders of magnitude
and three orders of magnitude bigger
cost
so usually machine learning methods or
active learning methods as we see them
they usually are set up for difference
in costs but
not really three orders of magnitude
difference so we really have to come up
fundamentally with a new ways that allow
us to
incorporate feedback right as we are
generating molecules or molecule
combinations
right we want to come up with a way
that will tell us how to run this
oracles of so different costs
and right now fundamentally this problem
is not solved
yet uh and the next thing that
another big set of challenges that we
are trying to solve
is basically what are the mathematically
solid foundations
right to simulate biophysical systems in
general
right to give you an idea uh right now
there are a lot of papers on let's say
graph representations of molecules
and there are a lot of papers okay we
can represent molecule as graph
as string as point cloud as wave
but there are so many of these
representations so
and what we are really trying to do here
is saying okay what is a very
fundamental way to represent molecules
right because we want to get molecule
energies right
that energy could be energy of a
particular conformation that energy
could be energy and for particular
conformation
in the context of protein binding uh
that energy can be uh just basically
integral of many conformations if you
want to compute at once
which will basically describe something
like free energy
right and we want to come up with a
certain way to simulate molecule but
there are so many of these
representations and there are so many
papers which each of them claims to have
better results somewhere
and fundamentally is molecular graph is
it's a point cloud is it something else
uh what we are really doing here right
we are developing a fundamentally very
new kind of representations
right which are kind of nicer graph
neither point cloud
neither something else because what we
are doing is we are going very for the
very first physical principles and
looking at this we can say okay what are
the most important properties
that we really want to have for momentum
and this properties would be something
like
okay when we rotate the molecules energy
doesn't change right so we do want to
have rotation like with variance
right and
in terms of energy this will be
rotational and variance but in terms of
force we really want to have rotation
like variance right which is basically
when we are rotating a molecule
the force vector should rotate the same
or something like a dipole moment right
vector properties should rotate
right so we want something like this uh
what we want
next right is we also we want to be lip
sheets continuous
and what does it mean to be lipschitz
continuous so whenever we perturb
coordinates of the molecule a little bit
right a tiny tiny bit by infinitesimal
amount we want the energy to also change
a little bit
right and uh this is very important
because if you want to have
3d aware simulations of molecules you
really have to have something like this
right and
there are also other key challenges
right so how to propagate information
within the molecule graph or within the
molecule point cloud or between atoms
right uh it's fundamentally a
challenging problem because if you look
at usually the data sets uh that are
more used right now for machine learning
communities this has data sets such as
qm9
luckily there are efforts by pharmaco by
startup or pharma companies where they
try to be a little bit more
biologically inspired so they do
evaluate on zinc and they some more drug
like molecules
but the problem there is we really want
to be able to pass a signal or
information
right thinking about how forces work
right we have some long range forces
which are electrostatics and things like
this
but we have also short-range forces
which are bonds
and bond rotations and angles and we
need to incorporate all of this
uh so our i would say very key paper
which is i would say the very first step
of us in this direction is something
called tpn right which is a tensor
passing neural network
and what this tensor passing neural
network specifically does
is that uh instead of passing messages
which are vectors
right it passes messages which are 3d
aware which are tensors which describe
deformation second order deformation
right and the equivalent with rotations
right
and then we also basically in terms of
the graph solving problem
uh in terms of the signal propagation
problem right we have
different versions of sending the signal
so we have certain amount of signal
traveling from atoms which are far away
from each other
but there is really a low bandwidth and
we also have
certain hierarchy right so the molecule
is represented as a hierarchy of blocks
so very much like was initially i would
say
in in sort of in machine learning that
was first introduced verigina barzillai
but it's an incredibly efficient method
right uh so this is kind of uh
representation we are working on
and now today we will talk about one
specific application
and more specific about specific
implementation of one specific
application
so to say what it is right um what we
really want to do oh like
back back i still had that slide yes so
this is a wholesale simulator
so and why do we need a full cell
simulator
right and there are many reasons for
this
but in particular what we're interested
in we have seen let's say
cancer drug combinations right and we
know that
uh for women right just probability of
developing a breast cancer is
about 10 in the united states during the
lifetime so that's a lot
and we found this study which really
really inspired us of drug combinations
predicted by a huge panel so there was a
study
by nih but they were also a bunch of
startups like rail and
others and foundation medicine
participating in that
so basically what they did they said
okay we will put a huge panel of
physicians
and this would be called a cancer
discovery panel and it's a huge panel
it's like 35 people
uh and this quote and basically what
they will do is they will describe a
drug combination for a stage four cancer
drug patient
right and the other way we will do treat
them with the standard of care
and the study was called i predict and
the results were released
about half a year ago and there is a new
one which is much bigger
which is currently running and what they
have found is that if they have this
huge panel of physicians
uh if in the control the control group
of stage four cancer patient none of the
patient survives
then when they have a panel of
physicians under incredible amount
of effort and you know looking at this
molecular diagnosis
they actually about 20 percent of
patients able to survive during the
course of study which is about 18 months
and it's statistically significant and
there are also
other like good correlations like for
example tumor keeps to be the same
right so the size does not decrease the
size of the tumor is stagnant in many
more
people in the group which receives the
combinations described by patients
so we were really really interested in
this so we're thinking okay
so what can we do in order to build so
because we cannot test
a lot of combinations of dioxide what we
can do to build
a really good cell simulator right and
some sort of problems which we
encountered are
first if you look at like dry
combination like
current drug combination models in
literature they models like decagon they
they're written in tensorflow
unfortunately really really really slow
so
basically just running dicagon which is
uh
published by mariam kazetnik and george
leskovitz group
running that on the same data set it
takes about a week
on the data set of just predicting
direct side effects
right and one of the child our very
first challenge to even get started was
how to write this efficiently
so what we did is we moved the full data
set on the d on on the virtual run on
the gpu directly
and then we started doing computations
there so from the time of
about week to ten days training we
transitioned to four hours time of
training
now we can run some experiments right
uh then we did basically this was mostly
published but we just happened to apply
already published algorithms to a
problem which we really want to solve
so there was a method called large scale
uh
lrga which has large-scale growth
global attention approximation and this
appears to be very very important
to have a graph like this with a high
degree of connectivity to be able to
efficiently pass the information
to basically have certain feature which
certain feature vector
which represents the global state of the
graph which will be used for
conditioning on the message passing
another set of challenges is that there
is so much data now
so if you look at cells so there is so
much data there is transcription binding
factor like chipset
and then there is binding drug protein
bindings and there is functional things
like crispr interactions
right so what we did for now we at least
managed to integrate in our simulation
pipeline and we integrate the
transcriptomics pipeline
right so our model can take
transcriptomics as an input and we show
that it's very very efficient
uh and finally then basically we started
looking as you know current
graph models for synergy predictions and
then we just figured out that you know
it's not even correct to represent
models the way they are
because when we have a system right so
what we want to simulate is a cell
and we are simulating a picture
perturbation on the cell
and the way the graph and model work is
that basically they have many many many
different drugs and all of these drugs
want to pass messages
to this all of these proteins in the
cell
right and then simultaneously this graph
somehow wants to predict
uh all of the pairwise drug interactions
right so all of the drugs are present in
the cell at the same time
and at the same time we are trying to
predict all of the possible synergies
so this is incredibly complicated to
learn so basically what we
did and currently are doing is
redesigning the framework of how graph
learning happens for molecules
and that basically includes
uh something we call signal on the graph
framework right or the simulation
framework
where we basically have a simulator
right which is a graph which
exists in a certain state and then we
adding two drugs and we are able to
simulate it and predict the outcomes
but with the same system we also able to
model other determinations
like uh such as for example gene
knockout
and finally the most exciting part for
me is active learning on cells
so of course there are many many
possible
implementations of what we can apply
drug combinations to right now we
concentrate on two
uh one is drug combination learning with
mike tyres
i had irik and this is our long-term
collaborator and
basically there we are using cells to
predict new efficient
uh cancer combinations but also there is
another one which is
uh basically drug combinations for kovid
19 which we really really really
now because it's a very urgent problem
uh and this the rest of the stock and
while i'm speaking there are already
some experiments running so this is kind
of exciting
so we are running our first early cell
experiments
as we talk and uh
the rest of the topic will focus on a
very specific application which is
how we can use drug combinations to
target kovid 19.
next like this
so this work is performed uh thanks to
our collaborators
and we are funded by bill and melinda
gates foundation and we work
very densely with relation therapeutics
and
this work of course wouldn't be possible
without them
uh but today as i am representing mila i
will represent
the rest of this talk will be on the
results that
we did specifically machine learning
models that we did inside miller
next slide
next as well right
so this basically is a very generic
slide so this is
basically usually the process of drug
discovery we talked about the nova drug
discovery
right and sinking into this context of
kovit we have an urgent problem
right which is basically we want to be
able to
solve to do something for kovit now
because
it's it's a very huge problem and you
know the drug discovery will likely
take a very long time right so if they
have seen
there are important drugs that are right
now
are being used in clinics and there are
two success cases
one of them is ramdesevere right energy
severe
is in transcriptase inhibitor developed
for some other virus
and they have been extremely promising
clinical trials data where they show
that
patients who take rendezvous recover
faster
and another one is dexametazone which is
a hormone
and i'm not exactly sure
why it works efficiently but as i
understand it reduces inflammation
uh so basically now we are thinking okay
we found one drug and there are a bunch
of other like there was recently by
another study founded by bilingual
indigenous there was another drug which
seems to be
even more potent so called epilamod
which is a failed drug for your mother
arthritis which seems to inhibit
covariant in that cells
much by far better than ever
so now is the question okay so appealing
mode is moving up
the clinical trials they did their mouse
tests so what can we do
as a machine learning community what can
we do for kovid 19
right and uh
what we are focused on is basically we
are trying to discover new kovid 19 drug
combinations will likely will include
them this
year but also one of other 25 000 drugs
and maybe two of other 25 000 drugs
already approved to be
taken by humans next slide
uh so what we are looking for is
so-called synergy right so in this
particular example we look for two
examples and synergy means is whenever
we have two drugs
the two drugs together are more than
each of the individual ones
right so we have an added effect and
this is something that we would be
looking for
and in this case we assume there might
exist a combination of two drugs
which is more efficient than a single
drug where i can disappear our pili mode
alone and what is shown on the slide
here
is basically if you have two
concentration of a drug usually when we
add two drugs
in the cell right and now we talk in the
context of a cell
all the rest of the talk is in the
context of a cell because there are also
synergies on the level of the organism
but right now we'll just talk in the
context of a cell because that's
something we can do and validate very
quickly
so basically if you add two drugs we
expect the combination or the combined
effect of them to be linear
and sometimes the two drugs can prevent
each other from working
and i can give example from a code right
so to cure codes there are two different
ways to cure a cold
either we increase than the number of
cough from a person
right so this cough goes away or we
basically trying to drain
the bronx right so we try to take liquid
in and then person doesn't cough anymore
and this tool would be antagonistic
right and here
what we are looking for is synergistic
drug combination right
and there are a lot of examples of this
in clinic if you look at hiv
or tuberculosis there's some multi-drug
combinations that apply to the treatment
of patients and that's something we are
looking for for covet
our next slide
and so what we are doing here is if we
try to take
we just basically if you're looking at
the time that we need to try to look at
all the pairwise combinations right the
kovid appeared very recently
right and there are in so-called refrain
library which is all fda approved drugs
which exist as a huge library
which is funded by bill and melinda
gates which is one of the major finding
efforts for which they invested
uh probably about 50 million to just
make all of those drugs and store them
together
to search just a pair-wise combination
not a triple combination pair-based
combination if you screen for 5000
molecules a week
which is actually something we cannot do
this is the most optimistic estimate one
can get
because this covid19 cells they require
bsl3 lab
and this is extremely expensive and
extremely low throughput club
that will take 300 years to search for
dracula all the recombinations
and this is not something we can do so
this is
uh way too slow we need something that
we can do
in probably months from now so what we
do is we apply machine learning to
basically try to search this space
and we do it in an active learning
setting
next slide
and basically here we have this
combination of
right one we want the agent to learn as
much as possible about the space of
possible molecules
right which is basically tries to say
okay which combinations i didn't try
before which combinations
by trying more of them it will learn
most and this is a setting which is very
well explored in machine learning
and another thing it also wants to be
greedy right because
it has a limited number of trials is a
limited number of trials we want to
achieve the best possible effect
right and basically training this agent
which boss explores and
learns about the space of possible
molecules is the problem that we are
trying to solve
and paul can take from here and
show a little bit more practical results
that we actually have been able to
achieve
yes thanks a lot uh maxim for the
presentation
and do not hesitate to ask questions uh
at any time we'd like to to have it uh
interactive
i'm not sure if you can unmute yourself
but uh feel free to ask questions in the
q a
and we'll make sure to answer them
during the talk
so as my team explained it's a
big challenge to explore the space of
all drug combinations
and the the question of how to
efficiently explore the space of the
composition is complicated
and here we present like our approach
for
to start this program which involves
machine learning and active learning
so basically this is like the big
overview of
our proposed pipeline and
as you see it's like the lab where
the compounds are tested and a machine
i'm learning a pipeline
which interact together in a loop so
basically
experiments uh will be performed in the
lab on some
drug combinations and then the results
will be sent to
the machine impact line which will be in
charge of recommending
the next uh drug combinations that will
be tested
uh in the lab and this is expected to
take like
around one one week per group and
we expect to to have the experiments
running
in a few weeks from now and it will last
for a few months so we'll be
actually able to test lots of
combinations and
today we'll uh specif specifically focus
on the machine and part of the
pipeline as this is what maxim and i
and others have been working on
so this is a zoom in in the machinim
pipeline
which has like three main components
so first the data which is like a very
important
part of course so the known synergies
for
some of the drug combinations and this
part will grow
along the time when more experiments are
performed
and we also have other kinds of data
which correspond to
more general biological knowledge such
as
fingerprints genuine ontology drug
targets protein protein interactions and
differential gene expressions we'll
go over this in more details later
and then we'll aggregate all those data
modalities and that's a big challenge to
be able to
aggregate all these data together and
use it in a
one-pack machine only pipeline and our
proposed solution
involves craft neural networks as some
of those data have a graph structure
and the graph neural network will be in
charge of predicting the synergy or the
antagonism
of drag pairs and synthetic pairs
that are that haven't been tested so far
and this model also needs to to
model uncertainty as this is a key
component to be able
to explore the space uh object
computations uh
efficiently and the third component of
the machining
pipeline is what we call acquisition
function
and that's the part which is in charge
of deciding
um which combinations will be
queried next and suggested
to the lab so that they perform
experiments on those specific
combinations
and now i will describe in more details
uh
the data that we use so some
uh of this data is uh
like used just as a
the purpose of training our algorithm
before the
data is acquired such as the
differential gt expression for example
but other data will be used uh also
during the
domain white the main experiments are
performed so there are four big parts
the first one is the protein protein
interactions
which model like interactions that
happen
within the cell between proteins so
those interactions can be of many type
it can be protein protein binding for
example
it can also be scrapped with nlp
from the bioinformatics literature
or the biology literature we use four
different
uh databases uh which are publicly
available
our name is string snap hurry and
biograde
and another key in component
is uh having information about the drug
so for now it's um quite simple we we
use a morgan fingerprint which is like
a widely used tool in bioinformatics and
that's one of the components on which we
could improve on the future
in the future by using fancier methods
um that are being developed
right now in other parts of the project
maxim mentioned earlier
and we also have access to the
drug targets that is to say the
basically the proteins
with which a drug is expected to bind
and that's also like a key information
to have in order to
be able to predict the synergies between
drugs and
what's the effect of a given drug in the
cell
and for that part we use two different
databases the drug repurposing hub and
kmdl
and the last component is differential
gene expression
which we expect to acquire at the same
time
as the drug synergies when the
experiments are being performed in the
lab but for now we use the
cmap l1000 dataset as a way to
to train our
machine on pipeline beforehand and
basically
what is differential engine expression
more specifically it measures
the the concentration of mrna
corresponding to different genes in the
cell and the more
the higher level the higher
the expression of a gene is the more
this
gene is used in the cell that's a
purpose explanation but that's the main
idea
and basically we can then compare the
difference in
gene expression before and after a given
drug
has been applied in a cell and that
gives us a very
nice insight into what's the effect of
the
drug in a cell and we hope to
leverage this insight in order to better
understand the synergies of the drugs
and now i will describe the graph neural
network pipeline that we came up with
it's a bit technical so um
maybe some of you are not very familiar
with the uh
like details of machine learning but
like please do not
hesitate to ask questions and i try to
to
have the like to present the main ideas
of the of the pipeline
so as i mentioned uh some of the data we
use namely the protein protein
interaction networks
as well as the drug targets have a graph
structure
so we use gcn and the graph that we
consider is composed of both
protein drugs and drug protein nodes
sorry and drug nodes and so our
graph has two types of nodes so drugs
and proteins
the fact that there are two types of
nodes um which have like a
really correspond to different things
may uh made us use
like a what we call multi-message gcn
that is to say compared to a
regular gcn which send messages between
nodes here we have different types
of messages for different types of
connections so we have messages
for corresponding to direct target
interactions
and we also have messages
for protein protein interactions so
we also have like a cell groups which
are in charge of propagating the
embeddings of the different nodes
across the different layers of the
network
and in order to better understand the
long-range interactions within the cell
across the network
we use a lower rank attention attention
which is like a slight variation on the
regular
attention mechanism that some of you
might be
familiar with and it allows to scale the
attention mechanisms to
many more entities here if we use
so for now we use attention between
drugs so a few thousand nodes
but we are planning as well to use
attention between proteins and
it's around like 20 000 nodes here so it
becomes very tricky
and compared to the basic attention
mechanism here there is no
sigmoid um as a softmax
function sorry so basically it allows us
to compute the matrix products
in a different order and it means that
the big attention matrix
is never explicitly computed and that
makes it
much more tractable and finally
in order to predict the synergy of a
given pair of drugs
we use a predictor which is like a basic
mlp
that we can condition based on the cell
line on which the experiments have been
performed so we
we have um different ways to condition
the mlp it can be film conditioning
which is like a specific technique to
condition with a few parameters uh each
layers of the mlp
or something like more basic like shared
layers
uh for all cell lines and then cell line
specific layers
and another key component of the
pipeline that i will describe
briefly here is to estimate uncertainty
and it's a key component of the pipeline
that allows us to address the
exploration exploitation dilemma that
maxim described
earlier and that's typically achieved
in like what is called a bayesian
learning by having a prior distribution
on the weights
of our model and
what it allows us to to do is to
predict the whole probability
distribution of the synergy
for a given pair of drugs instead of
just having a point estimate of the
synergy like just one synergy predicted
for example
but to have a whole distribution and
that's a much richer
information that we that we predict here
um
without maybe going too much in the
details there are lots of
problems that arise when combining
beijing learning to deep learning
depending on the different techniques it
can be like
untractable if we try to do something
very complicated
or some people have tried to make
simplifying assumptions
by having like simple posterior
distributions on the weights
but it wasn't working very well
and one nice approximation
that has proven to be very effective is
monte carlo dropout and this is
what we use uh in our pipeline there are
other ways that we could deal with this
um
problem we could use ensembles and
that's the sort of direction that
we are trying to explore and very
intuitively
for uncertainty what is uncertainty
there are many ways to
define it one way to define it is to
consider that it's
the variance of the probability
distribution of the
synergy of a given pair of drugs as
predicted by the
network so if we haven't tested a given
drug
yet we don't really know what would be
the synergy but maybe we have some idea
and if we don't know at all what the
synergy will be
the variance of this probability
distribution will be high
that's for the main intuition
all right and now i will talk about the
first the third component
of our pipeline acquisition functions
which
um are a key component to direct the
search of the
direct combination space so very briefly
watching is an acquisition function
it's a function that uh computes a score
for each drag pair given the probability
description of the synergy given the
direct pair which is predicted by our
crack cracker network described before
there are
different strategies possible so for
example
just uh the gd acquisition function is
very simple and it's pure exploitation
and no exploration at all
that is to say you just the score is
just
what's the expected uh score uh
synergy for your direct pair as
predicted by the model and then you will
query the pairs that have the highest
expected synergy uh you have the
opposite approach which is a random pure
exploration
in this case this the the acquisition
function is just a random generator
and you will it means you will select at
random the next experiments to perform
so that's of course not optimal and
that's
those are the two extremes and then uh
they are like
a fancier approaches which are
in between the two extremes and that try
to
take advantage of the uncertainty in
order to
explore a little bit while driving the
exploration in the right direction so
there is expected improvement
in which basically you want to focus on
the
drugs for which you expect to improve
the most compared to the best
drug combination that you have seen so
far and
as described before it can be estimated
quite simply using
empty dropouts there is another approach
which is
gpucd and here so it's a bit different
from
expected improvement as we do not focus
on the improvement
but we will focus on just the drugs that
have a high uncertainty that's to say
the
standard deviation of the synergy
distribution
and you see that compared to the greedy
strategy you have an additional term
which gives more importance to the
period for which you have the highest
standard deviation that's to say like
a high uncertainty and so i will present
with you the results but uh
of course that's ongoing work
so this is a first slide
about early experiments that we
performed on cancer data
from the drug combat portal and the
a1000 data set
which are both publicly available data
set and which do not correspond to
uh coveted data but uh it's also like
experiments performed on
cell lines and it has many similarities
with
the the the problem that we want to
address in the end
so here we just wanted to explore the
importance
of the different features that we use
that's
quite insightful as as i described there
are many different
data modalities that we use and for
those specific experiments we just use a
simple
mlp there is no machine learning no
active learning sorry
here and we try to predict
the css score which is a sensitivity
uh score and we also uh so this is not
shown here but
we have many different scores that we
can predict energy scores such as hsa
this
zip for those who know a little bit
about those things
and you can see that overall here we
have a pretty good
fit with a 0.8 r squared that that means
that we can explain
80 um of the variance that we've seen
in the dataset with our model
and you can see that lots of
features like the pro the drug targets
and the fingerprints explain
well the what we see in the data and
we can associate that when we use a
differential gene expression
the model performs even better and that
means that the
the insight provided by the gene
expression data is
is a quite helpful for our pipeline
and then we want to evaluate the
efficiency
of the expression strategy using
different acquisition functions
so those are more recent results
still on cancer data and
we use the milky message gcn that i
described
earlier with like uh
the predictor is an mlp with a bunch of
shared values
and then cell line-specific layers and
what we see on that plot
is the proportion of the top one percent
synergistic combinations in our data set
which have been discovered by the
pipeline
so far along the steps of active
learning so you can think about the
x-axis
as a time and the y-axis is the
proportion
of uh the like the best synergistic
combinations in our data set
that have been discovered so you can see
that
the very naive
approach which is random acquisition
which means that you just
perform experiments at random and
it performs quite uh poorly of course
compared to the other one
and then when we explore the space
greedily or using
the fancier acquisition functions
we discover much quicker the
like the best synergistic combinations
and it's
uh in like a few steps eight to
ten iterations we discover almost all of
them
um one one thing that we see here is
that
the the expected improvement in gpu cb
do not uh perform much better than the
3d acquisition that may be like one bias
that
there is in our experiment because in
fact our data set is
rather limited in size compared to all
possible
combinations and it means that in fact
if
if you perform greedily just among the
examples that are in our data set
uh you will perform quite well and you
won't get lost
in the same way that you could get lost
if you had all possibilities
available so maybe in the real case
so of course that's uh early experiments
and we still need to improve
on this but in the real case we could
expect
this bias to disappear somehow and
debut the acquisition to not compare as
well to the other approaches
so in conclusion
that i think this project is a very nice
example
of how machine learning and
the the experiments that are being
performed in the lab can
uh interact together in a nice
loop as we saw earlier and that's very
exciting uh
to me and so that's not going to work
there's still
some efforts to be put on the improving
the model
and uh performing more
tests on our current pipeline um
in terms of research direction
directions in the
middle term long term there are lots of
very exciting directions such as
improving on the graph representation
and in part
as maxim mentioned a little bit
and as well on out of distribution
generalization
as as you see here because we use active
learning
the distribution that is seen by the
model is not static
and we the model will explore new
regions
of the space along training and also the
fact that our model
generalizes well far from the data that
it has seen
so far is especially helpful here
because
we use those predictions to actually
go and see what happens in that region
of the space
so um thanks a lot uh
to the organizer for hosting us
again and i would briefly present the
team
so that's a project in collaboration
with uh uh between mila and relation
therapeutics
and it's funded by the bill and media
media gates
foundation so the leadership of this
project
so so there is the professor yeshua
benjio
dr charles roberts and dr david roblin
and uh the media team which focuses on
machine learning
so there is uh professor yoshida job
maxim krabioff
jared director brooks isabel lacroix and
myself
and on the recovery side there is
charlie roberts
jake taylor kings benjamin schweiner
christian reject
thomas godley and jeremy haters and
uh that's a pleasure to to work in this
project and
again that's very exciting thanks a lot
and please feel free to ask any question
yes i have a question from your show
which i can read
uh your equated uniformly random search
with
pure exploration uh i don't think this
is an appropriate match in my mind pure
exploration would just be knowledge
acquisition like child play
not caring about exploitation
oh we see so again
which is good somewhere it makes sense
so your exploration would be just
knowledge acquisition like child play
not caring about exploitation okay sure
in the sense of achieving some extreme
secret of art like discovering molecule
which is good in some very particular
sense
yeah but uh yeah yeah this is possible
to do this baseline
so basically to paraphrase this baseline
it would be if we have something like
purely like bold
so which is much active learning to
improve and so just you have a pure an
exploration
yeah so we actually didn't have that
baseline it would be good to have
because right now we only had random
exploration
uh but not something like pure
exploration
so we had random acquisition function
but not pure exploration
now that's indeed a very good time so so
i guess here um again
um regarding the analogy with a child
playing here there's
there is no it's an interesting
comparison uh here there's no like
really like time dependence i mean
there's
dependency um yeah i'm
i'm not sure to precisely understand
what you mean yeshua but yeah
random we can we can we could we could
describe it against the
yeah exactly so you show us a short look
in the places she doesn't know
yes exactly so this is basically like
bold
yeah tries to understand causal effects
oh that causal will be very different
actually that's that's one very
interesting uh directions that we could
uh
follow that is to say um instead of
having an acquisition function which is
driven by
uncertainty it could be
like an acquisition function which is
designed in order to query the
examples which are expected to give the
most useful information from the causal
point of view
and that that would be very very
exciting so
if we think about modeling the the cell
with a
with a graph or other like uh causal
methods we could come up with some way
to estimate like uh some um
like drugs that target specific parts of
the graph
and that would give like the most
insightful uh
information from the point of view so
there are some
causal discovery methods uh out there
um which we did not talk about in that
talk
specifically but we we could uh probably
take inspiration from
from those things
thanks a lot for the question all right
once again thank you everyone for
attending and thank you for host for
organizing